i want to flip it over real quick rod to
this defense this cowboys defense the
pass rush that continues to form you've
been talking micah parsons defensive
player of the year
virtually the entire season randy
gregory turned into a leader you said in
the pregame
lawrence comes back how special could
this group be when they put together
this playoff run i think the only thing
that was really holding them back was
health you know demarcus lawrence i mean
we know about him we know his skill his
athleticism and what he can bring i mean
he's a 100 million dollar dude and he
showed you exactly what he's capable of
doing when he's healthy randy gregory
has i've really been impressed with him
for a goddess had a checkered past he
comes back he becomes a leader he's a
big part of what they're trying to do
you see demarcus lawrence and the speed
and athleticism and this is what he's
capable of doing when he's 100 healthy
but i love the defensive line look at
the defensive line man their penetration
and then when you add a fifth rusher and
micah parsons and create that one-on-one
match-up inside against the guards you
can't stop this that's why i say i am a
big believer in the dallas cowboys they
can go anywhere in the national football
league and win and win a playoff game
hot rod made some headlines he made some
waves in the pregame saying this team
that go to the super bowl there's a team
that can go to tampa when this team
would go to green bay and win who knows
they may still end up being the one seed
where's the weakness when you watch this
where's the weakness i don't see it i
just don't remember it used to be on
defense is it the secondary is it the
corners is it the linebackers where's
the weakness amari cooper told us it's
the deepest and most talented team that
he's ever played on in the depth the
depth and talent is what keeps showing
up chris sims do you see any weaknesses
when you watch dallas play tonight i
don't not at all i mean i think you guys
kind of hit it you know hit the the nail
on the head as far as i look at it did i
question maybe they played too much
man-to-man you know are they gonna get
up too many big plays in the pass game
but it doesn't really matter when the
defense is the defensive line is healthy
and has depth it just has so many fresh
and talented bodies to continually throw
at you throughout the course of the game
that they cause problems and then of
course some of those db's who are maybe
do play too much man-to-man they don't
have to play that long so i don't look
at see many issues with their football
team all together i really don't i'm
with rodney and the i think the dallas
cowboys could get to the super bowl i do
you know if you look at it and you just
throw it out to me i'd go well the
cowboys have more talent on their
football team the green bay packers who
are the number one seed team in the nfc
right now and i think rodney's writing
the fact that you can run the ball you
got playmakers and you got a defensive
line and an offensive line that usually
translates to winning on the road in the
playoffs in nfl football so i'm with you
the thing we just saw though hey i'm
glad we saw the passing game passing
game kind of start hitting on all
cylinders again dak was certainly off i
think calvin moore kind of felt lost his
way to a degree you know and you heard
cd they were making some mistakes across
the board but man the way they look
tonight you know the way they've looked
the last few weeks it's just continually
gotten a little bit better and you know
i'm with you jack and rodney i think
they're a real contender in the nfc for
sure
chris i'm with you too man as far as you
giving uh props to kellen moore because
i was on killing more hard this week
because i felt like all the talent that
they have all the skill set that they
have that dak prescott could be playing
a lot better and i thought he did a
great job of just you know changing up
the temple hurry up offense bootlegs
short intermediate passing game they
took some shots i thought kevin i
thought kevin moore um
kellen moore did a heck of a job with
his play calling you still get tyron
smith back i mean that's the scary thing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports